dos camiones y una pala cargadora en
llamas Este miércoles se produjo el más
reciente acto de violencia en la
convulsa región de la araucanía según
medios locales los asaltantes dejaron un
mensaje exigiendo la liberación de los
presos políticos mapuches
donde individuos con sus rostros
cubiertos y promovidos de armas de fuego
llegan hasta el lugar obligando a los
conductores de los camiones a descender
quienes luego ellos utilizando líquidos
acelerante proceden a quemar dos
camiones y un cargador la región de la
araucanía y las provincias de biobío y
arauco en la región de biobío llevan un
año en estado de emergencia este ya se
ha renovado 23 veces pero la
conflictividad no cesa el martes un
granjero recibió disparos en su
camioneta que le llegaron a impactar la
persona no están disparando a matar y es
por eso que hacemos el llamado al
gobierno a tomar las medidas necesarias
y a poner un estado de excepción
completo en los sectores rurales
en la araucanía vive en 1,7 millones de
mapuches en la zona hay grupos de
autodefensa que mediante la acción
directa tratan de recuperar partes del
territorio que consideran suyos
actualmente solo ocupan un 5% de sus
tierras históricas en el sur de chile
que ahora están en manos de empresas
forestales y agricultoras la tasa de
pobreza de los mapuches duplica la del
resto de población Mientras tanto la
ultraderecha chilena triunfó en las
elecciones al consejo constitucional una
constitución que tras su primera derrota
borró la idea de un estado plurinacional